can we install bad programming later
absolutely okay
when did you learn how to drive when did
you learn how to drive not before seven
i presume no ten yeah okay ah
so there's a different way of learning
there's the learning for the first seven
years which is hypnosis theta
but there's learning after age seven by
repetition practice habituation repeat
something repeat it and the more you
repeat it the less you actually have to
pay attention to it because now it's a
program you
when we were first getting in the car
when we were young oh the mirror is the
dashboard the gauges the engine sound
the wind what's going on so much
today you get in the car you put the key
and you don't pay attention to any of
those details they're automatic now
they're habits so we acquire habits
after age seven through a process of
repetition now the problem here is well
you can have a good repetition a good
habit or you're gonna have a bad habit
you learn both either way but when you
once you have the habit it's out of your
consciousness
you want to have a habit it's going to
be automatic and it's going to run it
because you're conscious 95 percent of
times not even paying attention to
what's going on outside
uh and therefore we are as the jesuit
said
we're not creating the life we want
we're creating the life we got
programmed to create right right
exactly
and unfortunately in the world we live
in
we become disempowered by programming i
say why because people knew if i
disempower you then i'm more powerful
than you
that's how people got more powerful did
they get more powerful i say no they
were powerful already you were powerful
but no you were programmed not to be
powerful and so we are downloaded with
programs of limitation that take away
our power except for those who don't go
into that what are those areas that deep
that program us with disempowered
limiting beliefs like what are those
areas i'll give you the biggest one
oh genes control my life oh
i am a victim of my genes so whatever
happens to me and i had nothing to do
with it the genes they go bad program
because epigenetics is the new program
it says no
your consciousness is adjusting your
genes you want to change your life
change your consciousness the moment you
change your consciousness you can create
a whole new life
kind of alluding to like news
you know television
um
that's kind of what i'm alluding to well
that that's the programming
you know
think about it this way you're driving
down the street and there's this family
having a wonderful picnic on the side of
the road they're all loving and they're
playing together and the family is
wonderful you go down the street but as
you go down the street there's an
accident on the other side of the road
guess what
you will rubber neck and you will focus
on that so you didn't focus on the good
stuff you focused on the scary stuff
because we have a program that's called
the biological imperative it's built
into every organism from bacteria all
the way up to humans i say what what is
that imperative
the drive to survive
a bacterium is built with a biological
imperative if you try and kill it it's
not going to go oh okay kill me no the
bacterium will do every maneuver
possible to stay alive so we are built
to survive
well to be able to survive you better be
careful of things that threaten you
so things that threaten you take more
interest
because i gotta be uh these things could
threaten me so i look at the scary
things i didn't look at the good things
i'm okay with them i got no problem with
that it's the things that scare me that
i pay more attention to and i go
consciousness is creating your reality
if you put a picture of fear
into your reality then your biology
behavior will manifest things to be
afraid of because
this is a short statement
but to me it's the most powerful one
simple and short it goes like this
the function of the mind
is to create coherence between your
beliefs and your reality
if i have a negative belief the function
of my mind is to manifest behavior to
experience those negative realities
if i have positive beliefs then the
function of my mind is to manifest the
positive experience but we get
programmed with so many negative beliefs
and that takes our wire power because
we're not focusing on the beautiful
things we're focusing on the fear what
are you afraid of yeah
so how can we create awareness for what
we're not aware to
what kind of
cues can we be looking for what kind of
situations in our life can we
become more familiar with to give us
this feedback this feedback loop of our
reality absolutely this this is the part
that all of a sudden i say well you got
programming i say when from the last
trimester of pregnancy through age seven
so i said well what program did you get
before you were born you go i have no
idea what that program is i said what
program did you get from zero to one i
go i have no idea my consciousness
wasn't there how about from one to two
no i have no idea so i say most of the
programs you got you have no awareness
of these programs yeah i said well how
will i know what the programs are now
thank god i have an answer for you in
the end
95 of your life is coming from the
programs your life is a printout of your
programs okay and i go why is it
relevant i say the things you like that
come into your life that you love to do
and all that they come in because you
have programs to support those things
okay but here's the one that's important
the things that you wish for desire want
in your life and you have to work hard
sweat over it
i'm putting a lot of effort in i'm going
to make i'm working i'm working on it
and i go
why are you working so hard but the
answer is beautiful because whatever
that destination is
you don't have a program to support it
and you're trying to override a habit
that doesn't give you what you want by
putting more effort into it and i go
good idea
not good process why
95 of your life is coming from that
program
uh and five percent from this little
conscious mind up here cannot
mathematically if you think about the
subconscious a million
times more powerful programmer than the
conscious mind i say and you want to
ride override the subconscious of
boy that's a [ __ ] that's not going to
work very well uh and yet there are ways
to do it because if it didn't this is
going to be a lousy interview but
there are ways to rewrite it and the
idea about it is
if you understand the process
you can rewrite your life
and change the outcome you can change
these programs sometimes in 15 minutes
or less okay but you need to know how to
do it okay uh the relevance about all
this is um
uh uh the movie the matrix
uh it's oh science fiction i go no no no
movie the matrix is a documentary what
do you mean i go premise everybody's
been programming go oh that's a given
we are all programmed from
last trimester to age seven everyone is
but in the movie they say well you can
take a red pill and get out of the
program
and i want to suggest that most people
in our audience right now that we have
here today have taken the red pill at
one time or another and their life
profoundly changed okay when was that
one of the best examples is when people
fall in love i go what do you mean i go
well their life is blah blah blah blah
blah they fall in love they meet
somebody 24 hours later
oh life is so beautiful i'm so in love
i'm so happy look i'm glowing look i got
growth hormone in my system
i go
24 hours later after blah blah blah all
those years and 24 hours later you
manifest heaven on earth i go
how'd that happen and the answer is
beautiful
because the answer is when you fall in
love you stop thinking you stay present
it's called staying mindful
like what does that mean i say when
you're thinking is when the subconscious
autopilot kicks in
if you're not thinking then the
conscious creative mind is the one
that's manifesting your life so
the moment you fell in love why would
you think and the reason this is you've
been waiting for this person your whole
life they showed up you want to think
and disconnect from this i go no you
want to stay present you want to be
mindful you want to be there i go you
stop thinking i say what's the result
it's the red pill
the moment you stop thinking is you're
not diverting to the subconscious
anymore you are operating from conscious
wishes and desires and so the honeymoon
is not an accident it's a manifestation
that says i'm not playing a program is
that like being in the flow
because you know when you think about
someone who's an artist and they're
creating a musician a chef
a chef or
or in love like you're in the flow right
so you're just because you're
you're not thinking yeah you're not
thinking you're doing and it doesn't
mean there's not participation it just
means that
you're not thinking of the future you're
kind of just well time and space sort of
change like you lose track of time yes
that kind of stuff yeah not thinking
means not diverting to the subconscious
meaning you stay in conscious creativity
yeah just creativity is wishes and
desires so
a chef
uh is so involved with the cooking and
paying attention all the details they're
not thinking and i say well what does
that mean they're not coming from
program they're coming from creativity
okay the artist the chef uh the race car
driver
yeah
not thinking man uh you know we're in it
we're going i had a monk tell me i
should write a book called the speed of
consciousness well that that's it
and the subconscious is much faster than
the conscious and that's why
in times of emergency the conscious is
too slow to help us and that's why we
jump to it but then the problem is
whatever behavior you're going to
express while you're in that
subconscious was the program that you
had a positive or negative well up to 60
of the programs that you downloaded are
not positive
they're disempowered
absolutely
so
what is it if we can take consciousness
a little further yeah what is it that
what is consciousness i know this is
like a we still don't have do we have an
answer for that even like why is that
why is that the the mystery and and what
is that what allows us
what allows uh what what is
consciousness
consciousness is the experience between
a stimulus and a response i got a
stimulus
and i'm going to make a response input
output reflex okay
consciousness get in the middle i say i
got this stimulus i have a choice of
responses i can make different response
if i'm not conscious then it's input
output just you know it's the machine
going this way so consciousness is the
freedom
to make a a different a different action
instead of just going input output input
output i got input let's think about it
oh i rather have a different output oh
well then that's your choice all of a
sudden but if you are programmed
subconscious doesn't have thinking it
says stimulus response program you're
going to repeat this your whole life you
know there the subconscious isn't evil
of course everyone thinks that's where
all hell comes from but the subconscious
got some great stuff in there like
when did you learn how to walk oh before
two how long can you walk you could be
102 you're still walking same damn
program you got when you were two years
old okay great program but a negative
program
will work that way for your whole life
but not give you the positive outcome so
the subconscious is a repository of
habits and then you can subdivide those
into habits that support who you are
and unfortunately habits that undermine
who you are
[Music]